part of what china's engaged in is
information warfare
that it gets out to all those nations
whether it's in latin america or africa
or anywhere else
where the chinese regime has been very
busy trying to
basically put a variety of nations into
debt through their belt and road program
how calculating and strategic do you
think china is right now compared to us
they'll invest decades of time and
effort into one potential asset
we don't understand how ruthless and how
focused they are
on their own best interests you heard
the whole story about they were pulling
out of afghanistan and here's what we're
doing it's been a waste of time for 20
years because of 9 11 why have we stayed
there
where do you stand with that we can't
stay there forever
we need to understand that when we leave
the taliban will take over again
jihadism turns our attention to china
chinese are going to respond in a very
brutal way and they're not going to care
what the world thinks about that
can another 9 11 happen with the way
we're set up today there's always some
element of a terrorist group out there
trying to come up with a new scenario
that will beat the defenses that you've
currently got in place we have gotten
better at not being reactive
we just have to think okay well what do
we do if there's a next
event
[Music]
so you know i enjoy interviewing former
cia agents but today
is a special one michael baker is a
former cia
covert operations officer president of
diligence llc global intelligence firm
and the host
of black files declassified on the
science channel with that being said
mike thank you for being a guest on the
entertainment sure of course man thank
you very much
so what what made you become a ci agent
i mean would you did you wake up
and say you know what i'm gonna go be a
ci agent how did that happen for you
yeah yeah it was uh i was recruited as a
toddler
uh i couldn't have been more than four
or five uh no you know what i i think uh
i would actually believe you they start
very early yeah
they actually you know what um i
actually long story short but uh
my daughter was actually one of the
first uh kids that went into the nursery
that's located there at uh
at langley i was back from overseas just
for a brief period of time needed a
place
uh for uh my fantastic daughter when she
was very young to be
and i'll be damned if they hadn't built
while i was uh away they built a child
care
facility and i used to joke about it i
used to say that's a great place to spot
and recruit you know new
new candidates uh but um
it's you know to answer your question uh
i don't know i kind of i ended up
backing into it a little bit it wasn't
something i
had planned on uh terminology wise
you're an officer as opposed to an agent
um
you know that an agent would be fbi law
enforcement that sort of thing typically
if you're in operations uh in the cia
then you're an officer as opposed to
referring to it as an agent
so do you just go apply to get the job
or is it is there a recruitment process
to it
there are it depends nowadays is a lot
different when i was
uh younger and and
you know uh it was it was more of a
recruitment process
you know there was sort of a spotting
effort that was involved i kind of came
across the radar i think of some folks
and
and it was a happy set of circumstances
that came about
um and i think they were willing to
overlook my dismal
uh gpa from my university days and and
they looked past that and saw maybe i
had some some potential in some other
areas and so
it worked out well in that regard but
nowadays
uh look it's i don't want to say it's
like any other job application but
they've got an internet site
you know you can apply online um it's
much more open than it ever used to be
and i think that's a good thing right
because
you know they they need to get out there
and look for for the best and the
brightest
by the way it wasn't me but they so
what'd you do before ci
what job did you have before cia uh you
know i was uh i was
headed down the path i thought i was
going to be
this is going to sound remarkable but i
thought i was going to be a broadcast
journalist
and i had focused on i've lived all my
life overseas basically
as a kid i came to the us for last year
high school
and so
yeah i thought uh i did you know the
usual political science
you know international relations uh
national security issues in
college i thought that's where you know
i was going to go and mix it up with
some journalism and
thought that seemed like a pretty good
path and and um
yeah you know obviously i took a left
turn somewhere
you know you know when you think about
cia maybe maybe movies have done this to
us and i've asked this
you know from other ci agents you think
about
the profile of a cia agent you know
foster kid you know that doesn't have
any attachments to anybody you know
doesn't uh
maybe isn't married doesn't have kids
parents relationship wasn't the best you
know
are those criterias that they take into
account
today or maybe back in your day or is
that just fictional
what we see and reading movies and books
yeah no that's a good question
you know frankly it's it's a little bit
fictional what do they want they want
they want well-adjusted stable uh
individuals confident um
some self-discipline uh common sense
you know they're looking for kind of
exactly what you would think right
because you're given a great deal of
responsibility depending on again look
the agency is made up of a lot of
different
career paths right there's a lot of
different uh
requirements in there and so it's a very
diverse range of uh
capabilities and skill sets everything
from finance experts
to scientists engineers um
and then you've got you know people like
me
so it's it's an interesting uh
organization because it's a lot more
uh it's a lot more diverse both in terms
of skill sets required and also just the
people
than uh the movies ever make it out to
be so you were there for 17 years what
are some of the craziest assignments you
had
that you can actually tell us about
yeah well that's that that is the
problem you just kind of your caveat at
the end there is sort of the
the restriction look i i've got a very
good relationship with the organization
in part because you know i keep my yap
shot about
um sort of the important things um and
one of those is kind of getting too
specific i will say that
uh i was in operations and i touched on
everything from
you know counterterrorism to counter
narcotics during the drug wars to um
you know sort of insurgency operations
um
and there's uh
there's there's in the operations side
of the agency
there is always an opportunity to walk
away from something
uh at the end of the day and think to
yourself you know nobody else is doing
this
nobody else right now on this planet is
engaged in this sort of activity
and and that is what kind of keeps you
fired up because
you know those moments can be separated
by pretty great distances you know you
could spend
six weeks sitting in the safe house
somewhere waiting for something to to
touch off
um and then you've got a moment of
something really interesting from an
operational perspective and then you
know you go back to filling out
paperwork to explain how you lost some
gear and
you know uh you know your expenses and
uh
you know it's so it is it's if they
actually made a feature film about
what really goes on i think it wouldn't
necessarily be as exciting as a jason
bourne
adventure it wouldn't be yeah so you
know i've had i've had a
nick mckinley on uh where he did some
work in the past i've had
jonah mendezon who was the former chief
disguise
officer who had you know the the head
of the skies of i think president bush
or somebody else that he should be open
it was believable i had piranto on i had
jane woolsey on
i had shabbat from mossad on it just you
know there's a lot of folks from
different uh
spaces that that i've had on and i've
interviewed with jonah mendes said
invest i said what makes for a great
agent she said somebody who's extremely
driven
extremely charismatic extremely curious
extremely competitive
but doesn't need to celebrate his
victories i thought it was such a unique
way
of describing a great agent would you
say that sounds pretty right on what a
great agent would be
yeah her and her husband tony who's
passed on great great people um and
and she's super smart and and i think
she
she kind of nailed it there yeah i mean
look you're not doing it for the money
you're not doing it for the salary what
is the salary bug what is the salary i
don't know
it's it's uh it's in line with the
government uh services you know the gs
pay scale
so which is amazing right if you think
about it
uh look when i started out and i started
out at a very interesting time in
sort of agency operations um
i believe i was making seventeen
thousand
and five hundred dollars a year now
when i look back on that and i think
about what what we were
happy to do for seventeen thousand five
hundred dollars a year
yeah you're not doing it for the salary
you're not doing it for the pay you're
not what you're worth right
yeah you're not doing it for anybody
patting you on the back what year was it
mike what year was it when you were
making 17.5
oh [ __ ] that was uh that was the early
80s right i got started i was in for
almost 20 years and uh so
you know that's uh you know but but
you're happy to do it right because
they honestly make you feel by the time
you finish up
all the training depending on what
you're gonna be doing um
you know i was ready to walk in front of
a bus for you know the director and
and uh the president so um
but you do uh if you're doing it for the
right reasons it's not
because you're looking to uh you know
get that constant reassurance or
constant pat on the back
right you're clearly aware that you're
doing it for something bigger than that
and that's honestly god that's
those are the folks that i always worked
with and ran across and
met and dealt with whether they were my
my uh superiors or
you know colleagues i mean to do
cia the job of a ci agent is one of the
requirements for them to
help you become a ci investigate to see
if you love america
is there got to be a like a certain
level of patriotism to be an agent or
not really
i i would hope so i would
i would like to think that's the case
and i would like to think that that
shines out
look it's um part of it
part of it is is a bit of a
self-selecting process right um
you know if you're applying to the
agency then theoretically
um you know you're you're you're kind of
already in that
camp right unless there's there's
something else going on that's that's
somewhat unusual so
yeah i think patriotism is an important
part of it you have and
again i i was one of those people who uh
never really you know i never imagined
myself to have all the information that
the the
uh the head shed or the top floor you
know the seventh floor has
and uh and so i never was one of those
people that would sit around and
question uh tasking or you know uh
operational assignments and and uh
i think that's a useful thing because
you don't have all the detail
you don't have all the information
you're a tiny little part of the of the
machine
when you're out in the field working
whether it's in paramilitary operations
or it's in
in you know narcotics carbon narcotics
or terrorism
operations you're just a small piece of
the action
right and all that that you're doing is
getting
put in the same pot as information
coming from a variety of other sources
or or
you know and and and then people that
are
paid to make those decisions take all
that and figure it out but
you know so maybe i approached it from a
fairly simple perspective i don't know
when you got him were you somebody who
did love america were you this is the
greatest country of all time did you
come from that mindset
oh yeah yeah look i you know i i uh
to this day i you know this this is i've
spent a lot of my time in very difficult
and in
uh unusual and challenging environments
and i've seen a lot of
uh [ __ ] but um
yeah this is this is a unique
country and when you say that though
nowadays people you know some folks will
roll their eyes and you know they think
oh yeah
what a load of horseshit but i i've been
in some
very strange places where people will
talk to you or if you have an
opportunity because of what you're doing
you have an opportunity to talk to
people folks may not believe it
here but overseas in a lot of different
parts of the world where there's no
opportunity
people still believe that if you come
here to the us and you work
you can accomplish just about anything
and it's that opportunity right the up
the potential for opportunity the
potential for equality
of opportunity that is
part of the magic of this country i'm a
little concerned that we're sort of
losing that here at home
uh for whatever reason but yeah it still
exists overseas
yeah it's uh i mean it's what brought us
here you know i grew up in iran and the
the fantasy was every time somebody
would get their green card to come to
the states it was a big party everybody
would celebrate and you're going to us
you know we
we'd watch rocky iv a hundred times we'd
watch
kremlins and we'd fast fantasize i don't
care if there is a gremlin just put me
in america i'll figure out a way
to deal with these ghosts you know i'll
be a ghostbuster if i have to i just
want to go to america it was a
a dream of all of ours to come over here
to america but
did you see the recent recruitment video
of cia i don't know if you caught that
or not have you had a chance to see it
yeah i did i did what do you think about
it
um well there's a lot there's a lot to
uh
to discuss there a i think it's right i
think it's a good idea
for the agency to
try to shine a small light on the
the work of the agency and the intel
community in general
uh and i know that's what they've been
trying to do over the past couple of
years
um and i think that's that's good
um to the degree that they they can and
that it doesn't uh
impact you know sources and methods and
all the rest of it and that's not
something they would do
the ad itself um i think they probably
could have
field tested it a little bit better and
and by that what i mean is
it's a it's it's a much more diverse
work environment than
people give it credit for it's not it's
not perfect but then again no
institution or business or community in
america
is right and they uh
and they realize that and they're always
trying to improve
but i think what they should have done
is taken
some of those folks who don't have cover
issues meaning if you're if you have
cover
you're not going to get in one of these
ads um and
and have various folks within the agency
talking about the challenges and the
excitement and the benefits
and the career paths available right
rather than talking about one individual
walking around and saying look i i'm not
i'm not
ticking boxes but then they proceed to
take a bunch of boxes
um or they talk about it as if it's me
me me
and almost in the by the time they
finish it's almost like what
people been assailing you have people
been you know claiming
all these things that you say you're not
like you you didn't earn this you didn't
of course she earned it she's there
right the agency doesn't you know that's
so
let me just play the first 30 seconds if
the audience hasn't seen it just for
them to get a glimpse of it because
they're probably saying what what
commercial are we talking about yeah
we're going to play the first 30 seconds
when i was 17 i quoted zora neale
hurston's
how it feels to be colored me in my
college application essay the line that
spoke to me stated simply
i am not tragically colored there is no
sorrow damned up in my soul nor lurking
behind my eyes
i do not mind at all at 17 i had no idea
what life would bring
but sora's sentiment articulated so
beautifully how i felt as a daughter of
immigrants then
and now nothing about me was or is
tragic i am perfectly made i can wax
eloquent on complex legal issues in
english
while also belting guayaquil i still
wouldn't think this is a cia commercial
no i'm still curious what commercial is
i'm a crying toddler with the other
i'm a woman of color i am a mom i am a
cisgender still don't know
i did not sneak into cia now i know
now you know is not the result of a
fluke or slip through the cracks
i earned my way in and i earned my way
up the ranks of this organization
i am educated qualified and competent
and sometimes i struggle
i struggle feeling like i could do more
be more to my two sons
and i struggle leaving the office when i
feel there's so much more to do
i used to struggle with imposter
syndrome but at 36 i reflect
is this the challenge the cia is having
where they have to make a video like
this to show that they're diverse and
inclusive
no i think this is just a uh this is
just emblematic of the times that we
currently live in right i mean i think
that
i think they're doing the same thing
that you know in a way
that coca-cola did by you know uh
chastising mlb or or you know
uh the all-star game or i i just think
it's
it's sort of a knee-jerk reaction in a
way you know and again not not
denigrating look she's you know full
marks to her she's you know
she's uh in there and she's working and
so she's clearly smart capable all those
things
right it just sounds like from the ad
that like i don't think anybody's
walking around saying she's
occupying space she's not supposed to or
or you know claiming all these things it
just
it just sounds it sounds very defensive
and it also sounds a little bit too
meist right rather than this is a team
this is an
organization that works together like
and when it works together in in
in the right fashion it is an amazing
thing of beauty from an operational
perspective um
it almost looks like the complete
opposite of what jonah mendes talked
about
jonah mendes talked about when you do a
when you become a ci agent it's about
being ambitious driven competitive smart
intellectual
charismatic all this stuff but you don't
need the recognition versus here it's
more like look at me it's about me
look how great again i thought maybe
they're doing this because there's some
internal
challenges going on with the cia where
you know not enough
latinas not not enough women not enough
african americans but i would assume
that in the cia you almost have to
recruit folks from different
nationalities and ethnicities because
if you're going into different markets
you need to kind of blend in i remember
one time my dad comes up to me
and we have someone in our family that
used to be part of the mi6 and
eventually we found out years later
and it's funny because uh that person
took the same murad as you
journalistic you know they went through
the media route and a boom they got
picked up sometimes that's
pretty common my dad says hey you you
can tell me
you can tell me i said what's that that
tell me it's okay i i know i already
know at this point i sit down honestly i
swear to god i have no clue what you're
talking about
he says how long have you been with the
cia i said you think i'm with the cia
city can wink if you are said that i'm
not part of it
you are it took him five years to think
that his sons
i'm like i'm telling you i'm not part of
the cia yeah he uh
till today i think he still has a little
bit of a skepticism whether i am or not
but
anyways i see this here i say i don't
know i don't know if the ad
is uh hey by the way has cia always done
commercials or no have they done no
no no it's i mean it's not the first one
they've done and you know again they've
got a twitter page
and you know and i i get why they're
doing it right i just again i just think
it's the wrong
path the wrong marketing message right
have you know she could have simply by
talking about
if she if she'd have been the same
individual and she had just been walking
through the hallways talking about
the the challenges the benefits of
working for the agency
right you're already sending a message
by having a deliver that but you're
talking about an organizational effort
a team effort and all those things so i
think the interesting thing about this
this particular ad is look they pissed
off both sides right they pissed off all
the people who are tired of the
of the woke-ism and think that it's it's
the wrong path to take and it's dividing
people
and it's also pissed off interestingly
all those cats that did talking about
uh wokism you know and that are all woke
themselves and
because now what they're complaining
about what they're pissed off about is
that
the cia has in their minds usurped their
language right
taken their language of localism and
used it for their own benefits so
somehow that's wrong
so both sides are are irritated by this
uh
you know you could argue that people are
talking about it uh and if that's your
metric
you know for success then hey fine but
it's the cia not
pepsi cola so i don't think that should
be the metric
yeah again if if they're trying to
target a certain audience
that's what this commercial got but it
didn't get
instead of doing a little bit more
inclusive it would have been better to
uh have everyone being there but again
behind closed doors you don't really
know what's taking place so let me get
into my questions i've got a bunch of
different topics i want to go through
with you
that i'm so curious about one of them is
this here's a question
black classify black files declassified
on science channel
it's a show that you've been running can
you give the audience if they haven't
seen an episode what's the show about
yeah it's the first season sydney uh
available on discovery plus it's a
discovery science channel uh production
we're just getting ready in two weeks we
go out and uh start filming the second
season
and the idea behind the show originally
was that um in a sense in a very simple
way it was sort of follow the money
if you want to understand interesting
operations uh
within the us government if you want to
understand um clandestine
uh services activities uh special forces
operations whatever it may be
uh latest research and development in
warfare uh
weapons technology then one of the
best ways you can start to identify all
that is by following the money looking
at the budgets because
money has to be spent so it has to sit
somewhere in some budget somehow
so that was the basic premise of it and
then it sort of branched out from there
to start looking at
a variety of interesting uh military and
intel community and government
operations and activities and
organizations and and people
and uh combine all that with some of the
latest technology that's being developed
uh
for some of those uh activities and and
just see what we can see so we travel
around the country and
uh you know it's a great opportunity i
you know i love meeting people and
and and seeing things that otherwise i
wouldn't see having a chance to do
things that otherwise i wouldn't have a
chance to do and
and it's it's so anyway i'm subjective
but i think it's the finest show made
for television
i love i love how humble you are about
it
but you know so episode number one the
secrets of space force number two
american ufos number three to catch an
alien
number four how to stop an assassination
number five episode five
iron man army six rise of the
night stalkers right all the very very
interesting
episodes but here's a question for you
so
i'll sit down buddy of mine was delta we
were in the army together at fort
campbell kentucky and
i leave i go into business he goes and
becomes a delta force and does great for
himself
and i said so what do you know what you
do all this stuff you know
there's only 800 of us and you know
we're the same level as navy seal team
six and there's everybody else but
that's us too and bubba also feel great
who's above you will report to this
who's above them we report to them
okay so you look at fbi you look at cia
look at dea you look at lapd
any kind of pd you look at the
government you look at military you look
at politicians
who is the ultimate puppet master
and what i mean by the ultimate puppet
master because i even think about it oh
when you become a president
you have the key you know you have the
key to the nuclear whatever i'm like
i don't believe that the president is
the ultimate decision maker
there's got to be some people who know
stuff
that nobody else knows that they know
stuff and they don't even tell the
president i i
i have a very hard time believing that
you're gonna tell a hundred percent of
the intel
all the darkest secrets of a nation of
the world that we know about the
mistakes
that we have the skeletons in the closet
which is probably a ton of them
i don't know if one president that's
gonna be there for four years or eight
years
you'd fully trust so who is the ultimate
power at the top
well it's it's uh actually it's kind of
divided if you're thinking about in
terms of who's got
all the information so nobody really has
all the information and nobody really
wants all the information when it comes
to
um a military element or
an intelligence community activity
whatever it may be because
it's just it's too much you're not going
to burden your right you're not going to
burden the president
with all that detail uh you know so
typically a president if you're looking
you know like the bin laden right you
present options right here
are the three options and you present
sort of a high level analysis as to
why they have been selected as scenarios
that he should
now have to choose from and you know all
that includes
risk versus gain calculations and all
the rest of it but
in terms of just you know specifics um
you know there's no one repository
there's no one book of secrets that
exists that has
everything and there's no one you know
as george bush used to say
no one decider right i mean there is in
the sense that the president will you
know
give a yay or nay on something perhaps
but it's not as if he's
doing that because he has read into
everything nobody could nobody could
get through that
yeah but there's like i i i i don't know
i just wonder
you know how much how much uh time
out of your free time that you have did
you ever commit to
studying secret societies did you ever
get into the secret society
stuff or not really uh you know what not
not really um you know
of course that's exactly what you would
say if you were a member of a secret
society
you're qualified you're fully qualified
because um i've had these conversations
before
um and people never believe me i i but
i'll say
i'm not typically a conspiracy theorist
right and and black follows the
classified that discovery show is not
about
uh conspiracies necessarily it touches
on certain ones but
not really and the reason i'm not is
because
i spent a lot of time kind of behind the
curtain you know watching
you know i guess how the sausage is made
to mix my metaphors
and uh what i
came away with is oftentimes life is
exactly as simple as it appears to be
and that may be some sort of
um mechanism for dealing with life
uh that i've developed but i i always
look at things and i
and i tell my folks all the time i tell
my kids this i tell the people that work
for me and
you know foreign that you never really
have very many options on the decision
tree
right whether you're out in the middle
of nowhere and you've got an operation
going on and now you've got to figure
out what to happen because it's all
headed south and
you know oddly enough your plan a and b
didn't work
um so you never really have a lot of
options i just always
you know there's very few conspiracies
or
you know uh ideas that i've i've seen
that
you know i walked away from and thought
yeah maybe there is something to that
so so the secret society thing i've
never i guess it just never really
caught my
my attention too much because i don't
really believe there's a cabal out there
who's directing traffic for the entire
world
yeah you know it's kind of like uh uh
the whole story about
where the koch brothers are talking to
each other so which president do you
want me to get you for your birthday
this year you know
let's go fund this one and you know on
the complete opposite side it's like
well look at the stuff that soros is
doing and
setting up the bricks for protesters and
you know oh my gosh it's soros behind
everything and he's funny
protesting he's funding that one part is
for a person to be naive and just say i
don't know if that's taking place or not
you did a c-span interview years ago
and you said nothing is black and white
you said you talk about when you're in
many countries your choices
aren't between good and evil often times
your choices between evil and less evil
right so that the evil and less evil
as citizens who go about their lives
you're like man i just got to go pay the
bills i got to make some money i got
kids i'm going to try to make this
practice here hopefully i can make it to
the game i hope my son plays and his
coach lets him in and
church man he's trying to really push to
raise money for this new building i hope
he doesn't come and want to meet with us
to give ten percent i've been doing two
percent
you know marriage we've been having a
lot of fights my mom is sick my dad is
sick my brother's going through issues
my friend and i got into a fight
so i'm just trying to figure this whole
thing i don't really have time to
think what koch brothers and solos is
doing
then you have the weird community the
weird community
is the why community that can't stop
asking the flipping question which is
why why why you would hope that would
stop when you're six seven eight years
old as a kid
you cannot keep asking that why question
at 40 years old right
yeah you you cannot tell me like there
is
not some people behind closed doors of
power that are making a lot of these
decisions because
if i sit and i think about okay let's
let's go a different angle if you you
know
instead of the secret societies let's
talk china
okay okay if if
if we were uh uh if america was a human
being and china was a human being there
are two people you know
america is two years old china's 20
years old okay
if america was uh you know 10 years old
america is 100 years old if america's
five years old china's
50 years old you know where i'm going
with this yeah yeah yeah you know so
america we're very confident we're very
confident you know freedom of speech
freedom of this freedom of that
but china is also extremely
you know quiet calculating strategic
long-term thinking they know because of
experience of having seen their former
rulers and leaders all the flipping
mistakes they've made because they got
a few thousand years of case studies
right they have access to
their own case studies right and when
you have all these case studies i don't
care what university you go to
it's personal we read about it we know
about it we know our flaws
okay so they know
the games they're playing i guess i'll
let you tell us a little bit on
what how how calculating and strategic
do you think china is right now compared
to us
well i don't think they're any it's not
that they're any smarter
um it's just that they've got a longer
view
right and it kind of comes down to what
you're talking about in terms of just
you know we've got the brashness and
confidence of youth meaning we're a
young country
um they you know have walked a very long
road
you know throughout their history they
tend to have a much
much longer uh view and that
brings patience um and sometimes brings
more attention to detail
so that gives them an advantage to some
degree
and that we're always kind of chasing
whatever object is out there and it's
shiny and you know we seem to have a
hard time focusing on more than one or
two things at a time
but uh yeah it's it's that i would i
would say that is
probably the biggest difference between
us not just from a
an intelligence or a operational
perspective but that is also
important they'll invest decades of time
and effort
into one potential asset
and you know all without any payoff for
perhaps 20 or 25 years
and then suddenly that asset who you
know actually
works for the chinese
intel ends up at raytheon or or motorola
or
you know the skunk works or wherever it
may be
that that i think is is
an advantage they have i don't think
we're going to be able to you know
develop suddenly a longer view you know
from our perspective
it's an advantage they have um um
as far as uh being united even though
our country's name is united
and you know we are the united states of
america and
china we don't have a clue what's going
on over there because you can never
tell the debates they're having
internally amongst their politicians
because that's never public that's
private to them it's their business they
don't think
it's our business to know what's going
on over there so we're like the husband
and wife we're our
uh we're u.s is more like keeping up the
kardashians
and china is more like a very private
show that only they know about
everything we do is publicized right we
know everything
the world knows our problems our drama
everything yeah
we have a short attention span and we
have a a tendency here in the states to
uh you know think
i don't want to make this sound too
simplistic but
we do tend to in this country
um think the best right of other
nations for the most part right we or
maybe it's not even that maybe it's just
we imagine that we're all in the same
boat together
somehow and we mirror our values
or the way that we see ourselves or
would like to see ourselves
onto other nations right so that hampers
our negotiations sometimes
when you're talking about a country like
china or russia um
you know the iranian regime the north
koreans because
we you know we don't sometimes seem to
understand how ruthless
they are and how uh
singularly focused they are on their own
best interests
while we're not we're the complete
opposite so yeah
who who can be bought more is is u.s
more for sale or is china more for sale
well i think we're more easily
distracted uh in terms of
yeah i i think yeah i mean it's it's a
very interesting question
it's phrased very interestingly um
you know i think the problem with with
uh with the way that we approach
china is that look the past four years
um
and i you know didn't have a dog in the
hunt in the past
you know presidential thing i you know i
like
i like republican policies i don't
necessarily need to like the person
who's leading them
right um but
i think we had a a relatively honest
open discussion about china for the
first time in quite some time right
some of the actions that were done some
of the things that were said
um i think it actually put the chinese
regime on their back foot they weren't
expecting
sort of that behavior because for
decades we've always approached china in
the same way
and always expect the same sort of
result that somehow they're going to
gravitate towards a more democratic
society that's horseshit
you know as long as she's in charge she
has set himself up much like
much like putin look putin's going to be
president until he dies
right and she has pretty much done the
same thing and he has completely
locked down the security services uh
he's squashed any hope of any
pro-democracy movement in hong kong
uh the the genocide with the uyghurs and
yet we continue sometimes to act as if
you know hey
you know these are people that we can
understand and work with and we've got
aligned interests and
you know maybe once in a generation our
interests actually align
yeah i mean it's it's is uh you you see
so much so much of the world relying
on this one country china whether it's
manufacturing whether it's
chips we learned during kovit we kind of
need these guys for pharmaceuticals you
saw what happened with india
400 000 people a day getting covered and
the officials of china send a tweet
essentially on their web on a on their
own twitter
website called weibo making fun of uh
india what they're going through versus
how look at us we took a you know
a a rocket launcher and these guys are
blowing up over there and then they took
it down because they got heat from their
own people that
called out the officials in china and uh
now india desperately needs 1.2 billion
vaccines and who's the only
place in the world that can get their
1.2 billion vaccines
and all the intel all the negotiations
the trade secrets that they picked up
is it too late meaning yesterday i think
60 minutes was done what a few days ago
with anthony belkin
uh uh i'm pronouncing his wrong name
wrong blinking
and the the lady asked the question
saying by 2028
china's poised to be a bigger gdp than
u.s right
is it is it already are we at the point
of no return where china is going to be
the largest empire in the world and it's
going to be very hard to compete against
those guys
well that's the narrative that they push
and and and part of what
china's engaged in is sort of
information warfare
right so so they've been beating that
drum that look it's inevitable
china's heading towards the top of the
food chain um
you know the u.s is a nation in decline
those things are
talking points that the uh that the
chinese propaganda machine has been
pushing out for some time and they're
very good at it they're very effective
at it we talk about russian
disinformation all the time but that
you know the chinese have far more
resource um
than uh than the russians do and they've
been very aggressive and active and
trying to
make sure that not just that message
gets out here in the u.s but that it
gets out to all those nations whether
it's in latin america or africa or
anywhere else
where the chinese regime has been very
busy uh trying to
uh you know basically put a variety of
nations into debt
through their belt and road program uh
lock up as much
of the you know rare earth mineral
commodities as possible and
and other and look they've got their
first overseas port now you know sitting
in
in djibouti in africa and
um that's not by accident that's
by design they are pushing out their
military aggressiveness in a
concerning way a very concerning way
there seem to be kind of accelerating
their timetable
internally when it comes to their
thought process towards taiwan
um so is it is it inevitable
uh no not by any means they've got a lot
of problems they've got internally
there's a lot more protest that goes on
internally in china than more aware of
um you know there is corruption that
exists within that that
that government that you know can at any
time
cause one of their people to topple
right so you know it's a very it's in a
way it's it's it's a relatively frail
system and that's why xi has been so
busy trying to
lock it down you know for his own
purposes and and
uh ensure his his longevity you believe
that you you believe it's a frail empire
where
well no what i mean is i mean parts of
the parts of the way the
organization and look i mean frankly i
you know i maybe i'm just stupid
and old school and and you know but um
you know socialism communism you know
they china's been around a long time
communism
has not right communist china has not
been around a long time
so when we think of china you don't you
you don't think
well this system has been around forever
no it hasn't so what i'm saying is
there's the frailty built into communism
and
socialism that eventually i believe uh
outs itself right comes out
and and then you know we see the decline
in whatever
nation it happens to be so uh
that's what i'm talking about i mean
they you know it may not happen
you know next year obviously or the next
decade or in our lifetime
but yeah i don't hold any water and
thinking somehow that china is
inevitably the next powerhouse
yeah who who do you think is afraid of
their government more is u.s
population you know more afraid of their
government or is
is china of citizens more afraid of
their government
well i don't know if it's a fear uh you
know the u.s
population is more skeptical of their
government um
it's a moment it's clearly a much more
open society
and questioning government is kind of
part of the fabric of america you know
and
being skeptical about your leadership
and and you know we've got that
ability and that right thank god uh in
china that's not the case right they
struggle to just get any details about
what's going on in
in within their government um or actual
news that's related to
any internal domestic events or issues
so
um i think uh the uyghurs certainly fear
the chinese regime uh and the
you know elements of pro-democracy in in
hong kong that used to exist and are no
longer
in existence because they've all been
banged up and
thrown in jail for the most part um they
certainly fear the chinese regime
it goes back to what you were saying
earlier though a lot of the population
there is just
trying to put food on the table right
and
you know they're still we we're we're a
little bit
softer right we don't have to go out and
collect water and food every day for the
most part so
um you know we have that luxury of
questioning everything
how uh by the way that's a great uh
comparison we're you know skeptical
americans versus you know a little more
afraid about the government what the
government could do to them
and i think it's even the most
wealthiest man in china jack ma is
afraid because look at them hey
they started their series of trying to
break the company apart hey you can't do
this you're thinking you're too powerful
you're the speech
you made you should have never taken a
shot at the government shame on you
look how much money you've made because
of the government if it wasn't for the
chinese government you wouldn't be as
rich as you are
so that's that part how how much
how deep is the us as far as how
infiltrated are we with
our cia agents in the chinese government
oh are we getting intel
uh you know what i i it's gonna sound
like i'm being
coy i hope so um uh you know i'm sure we
are whether it's through our own assets
or through
you know liaison work uh with other
countries um
you know that's kind of gets down to a
little bit too close to the bone to
sources and methods but
look um people here in the states better
hope that we are good at it and that we
are active
because the chinese uh regime the
chinese intel service
within the pla in particular is very
aggressive
very in and not just here but with all
our allies and they are busy hoovering
up every piece of information that they
get their hands on on a daily basis
whether that's through cyberspace or
through old-fashioned human sources
you know they have an enormously
aggressive uh you know effort
underway around the globe so yeah we
have to do everything we possibly can to
counter that
what what is uh okay so what what
concerns you the most about them is it
you know long-term i mean you know i
lived in dallas for five years
so when i left dallas the moment i left
dallas two weeks later
the storm hit and this was just you know
12 weeks ago 13 weeks ago
we had to shut down our office pipes
were blowing up one of my c-suite
executives
bedroom master bedroom upstairs living
room down here they were out visiting
grandma
the bed fell to first of all because the
knife blew up i mean it's just
red cartoons yeah it's like a cartoon
and it was happening everywhere
one day two days three days five days
seven days
we had an event going at gaylord and i'm
doing a conference call with gaylord
with my executives at dealer
we're expecting two 000 people there
they're in the hotel room lights are off
they have beanies on and four sweaters
on because the heater doesn't work at
gaylord and gaylor is a well-known hotel
yeah you know what if that becomes a
formula for somebody who's a little bit
more divisive in the
in asia a country called china saying
wow what a great uh what if we could do
that to us for eight weeks what if we
could do that to us for
you know four months what if we do bio
warfare what if we do
cyber what if we do yeah no it's
it's already in there yeah it's that's
already in their playbook they've
already figured that out in terms of
you know what the a major conflict could
look like
and uh and you know if you get all the
you know pentagon and military intel
community leaders in dc and put them in
a conference room and
you know ask them all what they spend
most of their time worrying about at
night it would be
uh you know an attack on the
infrastructure here in the u.s right
that's that's
right up there at the top of the list so
that's and that's something that happens
every day whether it's the
russians or the chinese or any other
nation that's got the resources they're
out there probing and mapping
uh our infrastructure and that's
everything from the power grids to
understanding how our our water
treatment facilities work
our transportation routes and hubs uh
the banking system
and and they're not doing it because
they're just curious
they're doing it because they're drawing
up or have drawn up
um scenarios for how that next major
conflict if it you know god forbid
should happen
is going to occur and it's not going to
look anything like
what you know we were used to from the
past and and you're absolutely right you
look at
yeah look at a place like austin when
they went during that storm
people were losing their minds right and
it was you know three days of power look
i
used to live in connecticut and you know
apparently when you
live in connecticut you have to sign
some contract that says you're going to
lose power
you know at least 10 times a winter uh
for days on end it's just
all the utilities that are above ground
and so a power outage for
for five or six or seven days was just a
standard practice and
if you had the wherewithal you'd buy a
generator and
you know uh so that's
that's not really a hardship but if you
multiply that by
six or seven or eight or nine or ten
weeks and
they shut down the east or west or texas
power grids
uh what happens well you you lose power
suddenly
things start to shut down you don't get
food you know delivered to
the stores because transportation is
shut down because now you're not moving
fuel around
uh you can't get cash out you know
there's no cash in your in your in your
atm
uh and there's a pharmaceuticals your
medicines
so that you know that's that's a real
problem
and our power grid as an example for
infrastructure was never designed or
built to withstand a terrorist attack or
certainly a cyber attack
but you know so when when the current
administration when the demonstration
talks about
dumping money into infrastructure
hell yeah i'm all about you know if that
means if that means improving our our
actual infrastructure our power grids
our water treatment facilities all the
things that
that we really do rely on that's
infrastructure if you put the money into
that
and your roads and bridges right great
right but let's not do what we always do
which is kind of lose sight of the
important [ __ ]
because we want to make everybody happy
by talking about the feel-good
stuff right and let's focus on what we
really need to focus on from a security
perspective first
sure all that up and you know maybe we
have a
couple of dollars left over by the time
we spend all that money
to uh do other things
i don't know what that's why i'm not in
charge that's why i'm not in charge yeah
so who who concerns you more china or
russia or maybe they concern you in a
different way
yeah they can certainly they concern a
different way you know that's that's
you can't again it kind of goes to what
we were talking about a little bit
before in terms of multitasking you know
we
and look the military the intel
community the staff are
really smart sharp individuals everybody
knows that we can multitask
in that regard uh oftentimes when i say
we can't
i'm referring to politicians uh but
uh china has far more resource than
russia does russia's got
you know basically the equivalent of
maybe the fifth largest gdp in
in the eu um and when oil heads
south right uh in terms of pricing they
really suck and win
and that's typically when you see putin
getting a little bit more aggressive
looking for some sort of external
you know enemy or target to get the
people focused on
uh which is another reason why we should
be energy independent because every time
we're not
every time we say we're going to do
something like shut down the keystone
pipeline and we're going to focus only
on green energy
guess what well just like people are
seeing right now your price of gas goes
up
and when the price of gas goes up that
you know
without a doubt benefits putin so if
you're
you know if you're in favor of of uh of
helping out putin great you know let's
not be energy independent but anyway so
those two those two nations
their threats are somewhat different
they all want the same thing which is to
push us off the top of the food heap and
ascend
uh it's just that china has you know far
more resource than russia does
who who's third by the way if you if you
were to say china and russia let's just
say they're at the top who's third who's
fort
who do you look at as a third is turkey
third is uh you mean in terms of uh
threat like who would be right uh we
need to
have our eyes on yeah i mean i think
typically
if you ask anybody uh in in washington
uh in the intel community of the
military they'll they'll say
it's china russia iran north korea have
and they've occupied those top four
spots they
sometimes they rotate or switch
positions but that's been the case for
you know two three four decades you know
three decades maybe
so that doesn't change much and then
you've got
up there in the top of the threats
you've also got again got this
infrastructure issue
um and you know terrorism is you know in
there somewhere but not you know
even during the heyday of isis was it up
at the top as an existential threat now
so it's but it is uh
it is remarkable how those threats have
remained somewhat constant
for a number of years now so so you
you heard you know the whole story about
they were pulling out of afghanistan and
here's what we're doing it's been a
waste of time for 20 years because of
11 why have we stayed there and then i
mean to to hear condoleezza rice and
hillary clinton come out and be on the
same page
about the fact that hey this is going to
be problematic if you do you're going to
face some backlash if you do this
where do you stand with that yeah uh
well look we do operational
missions we do tactical missions really
really well you know this year in the
military
and tora bar is a good example we do
we we do things very very well from a
tactical perspective
we don't necessarily uh nation build
in uh that part of the world
very well at all uh because in part
you know the the local buyers don't know
what we're selling
right and so my feeling has always been
about afghanistan is that look
we we did a great job in torabora that
was
that was a that was a hell of an op
right bin laden got out but that wasn't
necessarily we weren't
that wasn't the priority target was
getting them it
it was taking down the taliban now we
should have explained at that time
okay if you do this again meaning if you
allow
your country to be used as a training
base
you know to attack the west whether it's
us or allies we're going to come back in
here and do this again
because we do it very well and so
we'll come in here and kick your ass
every time we need to
and that to me would have made more
sense than trying to
improve the literacy rate or try to sell
them on some sort of pseudo
federal democratic government concept
in an environment where we know
from recent history from looking at the
example of the soviets occupying
afghanistan
we had the same exact problems that they
had when they were trying to exit
right they were trying to get they were
trying to okay maybe we got to retreat
to the urban centers we can't hold the
countryside you know
how do we leave a government in place
that you know will
continue with our agenda once we're out
you know that all the problems that they
were facing
are the problems we are facing we tended
to
mirror our values we tended to think
well you know it'll be different because
we're
it's america it's you know democracy and
it's freedom and
you know they don't know i don't know so
i think
what we uh we just need to be pragmatic
we need to understand that when we leave
the taliban will take over again they
will take over again oh yeah the taliban
will be in charge
so once we leave the taliban will be in
charge
and if we can't live with that well then
okay then we
we shouldn't leave but i guess my point
is
we can't stay there forever and is it
time to have a hard assessment as to
whether this is
you know one of our key priorities from
a national security perspective
so i just uh i'm not one of those people
that says we need to leave
you know five or ten thousand troops
there um
i think we just at this stage of the
game um
crazy question as long as we can accept
the fact that the taliban's gonna be
back in charge
crazy question for you do you think
china wants us to leave
china wants us to be bogged down china
wants us to to
devote resources in there just like
russia does russia was tickled pink when
we started you know
in there and because they knew i think
what was going to happen
and so china if
it causes us heartburn if it causes us
to expend resources if it
damages our brand worldwide
then china's all in favor of it i don't
think they necessarily want us to leave
uh because then they'll come rushing in
and fill a vacuum
um i don't think anybody at least
in the rest of our lifetime is going to
look at the soviet experience and our
experience and thinking themselves you
know maybe we can do it next time better
my concern is i think china may be
sitting there saying look america why
don't you waste your resources to stay
in afghanistan because as long as you're
there
the taliban is not going to be waking up
because if they do and they find out
what we're doing to muslims here in
china they may come after us before they
come after you at least you're not going
out there
you know doing to muslims what we're
doing out here you know the story about
what china
yeah well the difference they've got is
that the the regime the china regime
doesn't have to respond to anybody
they don't care right and they
understand that i think they look they
they get that they've they've already
essentially gotten they've
gotten away with what they've been doing
to the wakers you know we've gotten
upset
we've we've issued some memos but in
reality we haven't done [ __ ] about
what china is doing to the uyghurs and
so if they have to deal with
an insurgency or if if the taliban or or
elements of
of jihadism turns their attention to
china
chinese are going to respond in a very
brutal way and they're not going to care
what the world thinks about that
so you so you don't think china cares
about what the taliban are going to do
to them
i think they're prepared to deal with it
in a way that we're not
and how would they deal with it i mean
if you were to use your creative
imagination how would they deal with it
well i mean i think there would be there
would not be concern over over
casualties
um there would not be you know sort of
that
concern over how this looks to the world
um
they again it's not that's not their
calculation
right if it's in their best interests
they'll deal with it
and they'll you know clean up whatever
mess is left
afterwards but they're not gonna sit
around and ring their hands and have you
know remorse over because the world
thinks less of them
you know so but i'm curious to know what
they would do like would you
would you see them saying okay let us
attack you directly here's what we're
going to do to you
uh uh how would they go about you know
responding to the taliban that's what
i'm curious about because
it would depend on what that would look
like right i mean the taliban's not
going to
what are they going to do they're not
mounting an invasion
um so you know it would be
what is it is it is it uh you know
efforts to uh
engage in terrorist activity on on you
know within china
sure could be and if that's the case and
that's you know i suspect that would
be where it would would lie then like i
said the chinese would
would uh my feeling is the regime would
would not agonize over a brutal response
and that would not mean that they're
going to invade
you know afghanistan um because again
they don't view that in their own best
interests
i so i don't know it's all speculation
i'm just saying that
that uh from our perspective um
we've been in afghanistan a long time
they're not picking up what putting down
you know
it's a bit like libya do you think we're
gonna create some sort of
pseudo-democratic
stronghold in libya so you know i think
it's time to assess in a
much more um
direct manner what's in our best
national security interests
i think we can maintain sufficient
insight into what's going on within
afghanistan without having a large troop
presence there
and i think that would then allow us to
uh drop back in if we need to and
again in a tactical sense uh
so but to think that somehow the taliban
will be part of a peacemaking deal
and share government uh once we're gone
is is ridiculous
that's crazy i had noam chomsky on
yesterday and i'm sure you know who noam
chomsky is i'm
you know we probably don't agree with a
lot of things he says but there's one
thing that he did say
is he said something that made me think
in his book who rules the world
okay so in the book he talks about how
america was so fascinated with the
in the hunt of ben laden right this was
a 20-year hunt let's go find this bin
laden guy right 15 years whatever
like 15 years right we're going to go
catch him we're going to get him
and he says bin laden won the war and
there's been a lot on one he says
because america spent
3.2 to 4 trillion dollars
to kill one man so if bin laden's vision
was to help bankrupt america or get him
to spend more of their money
guess what he won you mean to tell me
one person's life is worth 3.2 trillion
dollars
so it kind of makes me think on what
you're saying is
you know uh america seems to be the
country that wants to get in the
business
everybody's war fight breaks hey guys
guys guys guys listen i'm here you guys
don't need to fight you know hey
hey hey hey like we're trying to be that
but but sometimes when you do that
some people want to fight some people
want to have differences some people
want to have their disputes
scored away and you're not allowing them
to do it then you become the enemy
because essentially two people turn
against you and they're like wait
uh oh get out of our business you know
why are you mining so much of our
business i think sometimes america does
that but
the taliban i think that like what you
said you said is america it's not about
whether we should get out or not it's
about if you do
the taliban's going to come up if they
do take over their
location are you okay with the
repercussions of what could happen what
are the potential repercussions
could a potential another 9 11 happen if
another 9 11 happens are we
prepared to prevent it from happening do
we have the right controls in place
how much is that worth have we spent
time in infrastructure and that i don't
know
but uh then the question becomes are we
ready for that
if that does take place can another 9 11
happen with the way we're set up today
uh well well sure uh you know
you know there's always some element of
a terrorist group out there trying to
come up with a new scenario that will
beat
the defenses that you've currently got
in place we have gotten better at
at not being reactive right remember
when truck bombs were the rage
and so suddenly the answer was bollards
you know put up lots of
perimeter bollards outside of government
buildings and embassies and
that'll sort the problem out and that
was reacting to the threat that had
already occurred
rather than thinking what else could
happen we've gotten better at gaming out
what else could happen and
so it's it's it's a different time um
but you know the problem is you can't
you know
you know you you lose if you just let
one get by
right you always you know just just one
just one slip and you kind of lost that
effort you know you got to be right all
the time
in counterterrorism so it's it it is a
it's a it's a tough
uh it's it's it's a good question i just
happen to think that we've got the
ability
when it comes to afghanistan to
obtain sufficient intel and
understanding as to what's going on
without maintaining five to ten or
fifteen thousand troops
in country indefinitely um
because at that point you're not doing
really anything you're just you're
afraid to leave
uh you're afraid to build up um and
it's i'm not quite sure who benefits
from
a situation like that um but
it's you know it's hard to imagine that
it's been
it's been that long that we've been
there three point two to four trillion
dollars that's a lot of money
and he's right that's what you know bin
laden talked about that you know rather
famously and and he was very open about
it you know
he is his part of his wharf against
america was
on the economic front and so
you know uh did you tell me whose life
in the history of the world
you know garnered the tensions of four
trillion dollars
of one country's uh you know resources
that's that's
that's impact right there you know yeah
no it wasn't it's it kind of
you know was it important to uh to to
bag him well
yes um did it become an outsized
uh focus
you can't underestimate the importance
of it uh
but yeah i mean i guess at the end of
the day
um you know he was you know he succeeded
in that regard right in terms of the
from the financial cost
of his actions to the us so
i never understood why we killed a guy i
mean you go to his place no one's there
he's by himself why do you kill him why
don't you get them and
if we spend all this money let's try to
get intel out of them let's bring them
back and see what we can do with them i
mean we brought
how much did we learn from what saddam
did remember when saddam was going to
court and defending himself and
everybody could kind of see how he's
selling himself and
trying to win the the citizens of iraq
over and some people are saying he's
full of [ __ ] i don't believe anything
he's saying but some people are like
well i kind of understand look at the
man
sympathize with him but no matter what
we got smarter as
a world to know what the guys mode i
just didn't understand why we have to
take them out
yeah well i mean you know in the moment
um if you're faced with someone who's
got a weapon and they if you're ready to
shoot you're gonna you're not
you know you're not gonna hear all sorts
of things about well
you know whether it's uh law enforcement
might they should fire a warning shot or
they should aim for the leg or something
okay well first of all you have never
been in a gunfight i i agree i'm not i'm
not
i'm not i'm not doing that but i mean i
think it's
and then it's also um
you know just from an operational
perspective i suspect bin laden actually
by that point in his time he had very
little
in his head of of interest you know so i
i don't know what it would have
accomplished it would have been a
a real dog and pony show of a of a trial
and you know there would have been some
people saying he needs to be properly
tried and you know
and so look the guy the guy got what he
deserved
um there is no doubt that it
it at enormous cost um but
you know i think now to to your point we
just have to
think okay well what what do we do if
there's a next
event like that of that magnitude and
are we prepared for it do we respond
properly
um you know my my
speculation is yes we would like this
country reacts very well at times to
diversity
even now when we all seem to be very
divided um
an outside event you know uh the u.s
seems to
come together at times like it never
ever does in other
you know times so i hope you're right
hope you go in that direction by the way
are we still would you still put us as
the best uh intelligence agency in the
world i mean i know
historically it's been the top three cia
you know mossad and you got uh
mi6 and now you got the the chinese uh
intelligence agency you know what do
they call it the ministry of a state uh
security of china you know who
who do you think has got the most
well-trained prepared anticipation
type of a group of people that are ready
for anything to happen
well we do yeah the cia uh hey look hey
you saw the ad we started out the show
with the ad come on
no i'm kidding i'm kidding not not to
denigrate the ad
but anyway uh but yeah i know the agency
and i'm subjective it's exactly what
people would expect me to say
but uh you know the cia in my opinion
anyway is still
at the at the top of the heap there um
you know it's not that not to say the
chinese don't throw an enormous amount
of resource at their intel
operations they do and they've also got
certain advantages in the sense that
they've got
they lock down their domestic you know
population like no other right
and they can get those people to work on
their behalf um
and to so it's you know they've got it's
it's like the old russian days during
the uh kgb
days you know everybody out on the
street every rushing out on the street
was
you know co-opted a sense to be a
surveillance in a way for
you know the kgb because they had no
other choice
um but yeah the cia's in terms of
resource capabilities personnel
uh reach is as far as i'm concerned is
at the top of the heap
i don't know
[Laughter]
power to you being diplomatic in your
your commercial for your peers to see
and say
mike's on our side you know but but i
you know what's crazy you know how i
think about it i asked this from
everybody i asked uh
shabbat he's like oh it's this i asked
woolsey
even for the two years he was in i think
he was in under clinton yeah
yeah you know oh it's cia and i i lost
different folks
but i think it's not mi6 i don't think
it's cia
i don't think it's mossad i think it's
china right now
because you know and and here's what i
mean by china look
who is right now doing the job of
espionage better than anybody else i
mean you you think about
what is espionage right let me
how many people are bought today i don't
know
you had world health organization
being more aligned with china you got
political people
in office that you have lineage to china
you know and china is willing to spend
the kind of money to buy people up in
different
ways and we'll give you this seed and
there's so many creative ways oh your
kid needs something don't worry about it
oh you're this person needs this
don't worry you need to go into uh
harvard let us buy a building in harvard
for 100 million dollars they owe us a
bunch of buildings so
a bunch of favors so i don't know if
anybody's doing a better job
it's it's almost this is this is almost
how i see it you go to a club
you see girls and you see the one guy
that's extremely uh
uh you know good looking so it's kind of
like uh so the girls are attracted to
him because of his looks you're like
okay that's mi6 good-looking group you
know
then you got uh you know uh one
that maybe they're known for being great
and bad and so
you have to know his reputation that's
mossad let's just say you know
you know this guy's gonna that should be
the agency
what are we good at board games are you
gonna get around to the agency
then you got wow look at this guy here
man you know he's
he's so good with words and you know
great uh very
proud and you know the kind of person i
want to bring to my family and introduce
him say that cia right u.s
but then there's the one that just says
look i have one intention with you
i want to take you home tonight and
that's it that's china they're shameless
china is so shameless with their game
where all the other
agencies are almost a little bit more
you know
careful in their ways of doing things a
little bit more
you know where they're just kind of like
no we are dark and this is what our
intentions are and we're gonna take care
and we're shameless about it and i swear
to god
if you screw with us your life is gonna
be held because we know your daughter
your distance that
i visualize them being that way again i
may be wrong
i'm just a regular guy here but uh i
think quietly
everybody's talking about mi6 mossad and
cia i think china's like you guys can go
get all the recognition on all the
websites on who you are but i think
we're kicking all your asses combined
together
well i mean there's no doubt that i mean
there's nobody's underestimating uh
chinese intel by any means anybody who's
in the game
and by the way it's good just to know
that the cia now we're known for our
you know sweet personality
um hey what the hell yeah
we're the ones that you want to take
home to mom you take an agency officer
do you disagree
do you disagree that we're not the
sweetest like look at the ad we just
made we don't
know i know but i mean but that's not
that's that you know that's a that's a
public facing side of it i've seen i've
seen
again i've worked behind the curtain and
you know we don't uh
we you know the job gets done you know
when it needs to
uh but i think nobody's underestimating
uh chinese intel for sure
um and part of it is you know uh
professional pride in terms of when you
ask who's the best
obviously you know but i i i wouldn't
expect you to say anything else
you you ask and you play they ask kobe
who's the greatest of all time he says
i'm first
i don't know anything else but that's
that's part of the debate no
i'm right i only ask because i think
some are willing to get way more dirty
than you guys are
well look you face the chinese intel
service and the russians
uh and a variety of others uh don't face
the same restrictions
and people don't believe that i mean the
sort of the progressive side the the far
left all those people who
actually believe everything they see in
a feature film or reading a beach book
you know they won't believe it but
there's an enormous checks and balances
placed on the agency right and it's a
it's the most transparent frankly
intel service in the world so is that a
detriment well sure
it is when you're talking about you know
uh operational
um effectiveness maybe uh because you
have to
you have to work within those checks and
balances and those restrictions and the
legalities that exist
the chinese don't have to do that so i
take your point in that regard
but you know um you know with creativity
and and uh
you know i i know i you can overcome
that i guess what i'm saying
again i have to respect your experience
and and just tell you that you've seen
things i haven't seen and i hope you're
right
i hope you're right but your opponent
can is
is willing to go to very very ugly
places
that i think america is willing to it's
like you know you fight somebody right
right and you fight this guy you're like
okay there's a knife there
you're not ready to stab the guy okay
you want to beat the hell out of them
and just you know let's just say
but yeah the other guy's willing to take
the knife you're not going to kick this
guy doesn't no matter how big you are
he's going to stab you right
so then you're like i'm willing to stab
the guy but the other guy is willing to
you know take out his gun okay then look
i don't mind taking out my gun
okay but then the other guys we're going
to go after your family oh draw their
line i'm not going
but there is somebody that's willing to
go to levels that you're not willing to
go to
yeah um well i mean first of all never
never reach for a knife if you've
already got a gun
so don't yeah don't make that mistake
uh but no it's you know what it is and
and that
is something that's used against us
right by whether it's china or
any other nation that doesn't have our
best interests at heart
uh is our our openness
um sort of our mentality uh our
you know again and and people sometimes
scoff but you know our desire to do the
right thing look we engage in a lot of
activities overseas
as a nation for the right reason because
we genuinely sort of want to do the
right thing do we make mistakes sure we
do and then we try to
course correct and all those things but
yeah other nations just like terrorist
organizations they use our openness and
our freedoms against us
right no no secret there um
but you know i would much rather having
spent bulk of my life overseas i would
much rather live in an environment like
this
than you know whatever china's selling i
i
i don't disagree don't don't don't take
my messaging as that at all i
believe no no america is the greatest
country in the world that's not where
i'm going
the place where i'm going is look things
are getting darker
and china's making it very clear that
they don't care to negotiate on
your terms the only way they negotiate
is on
their terms no american negotiate the
only person that's ever pushed these
guys that's pissed them off is one guy
and it was the most hated guy in america
in the history of america in a four-year
period
to the point where anybody was willing
to do anything for this guy tonight get
elected
on the opposite side and the person that
got elected is probably the least
qualified
not quote maybe the not least qualified
because his resume in the world of
politics 43 years
the least aspirational excitement 20
people would show up to
makes no sense and i don't even think
kamala harris today i don't know if she
maybe she did a press conference or two
but i don't don't recall her doing
anything there yeah
so i i don't know when i think about
that i've interviewed mobsters sammy
double garvano you know michael francis
all these different names that maybe
you've heard about phil leonetti from
philadelphia
yeah the mop system was what hey you got
a liquor store here joey
i do who's bothering you well such and
such
moving forward tell them i'm on you you
tell them sammy's over here
really yes guy comes to try to bully
joey
hey joey give me your money i'm not
giving you [ __ ]
excuse what'd you say you want me to
call sammy
oh you oh you call sammy yeah no no no
no no no listen joe i got no problem
with you no
to me again i'm not saying that's the
direction to go
but what i am saying is i almost expect
you know the movie uh what was the movie
with uh tom cruise where you can't
handle the truth with uh oh yeah
uh it was uh yeah uh up on the wall in
guantanamo
yeah with that you good man right where
the guy said
you can't handle the truth right and
the movie he goes because of code red
let's set aside code red forget about
code red
but i do think the job of cia or delta
or navy seal team six or some of this
what you guys have to do i do believe
99 of america cannot handle the truth
i believe that yeah yeah i know that
most most folks really don't want to
know how the sausage is made
you know it's just not something they
want to get involved in
and like you said at the very beginning
it's not something they have time for
right everybody's worried about rightly
so you know taking care of their family
doing all those things
people want national security they want
to feel protected you know and
so you know look
i guess all i would say is um
within the confines of of how
uh you know we operate as a military and
intel community um i still maintain we
are the
best out there we're the most effective
efficient group out there
uh that doesn't undermine the
seriousness or the
challenges from an organization like you
know the chinese
ministry so um but it does
uh yeah that that does present
problems right the and i think the
problem that we're facing right now is
exactly what you said with biden and
harris is
you know are they up to the task are
they up to the task of standing up
against
china and and dealing with them in a way
that
you know um they'll take seriously and i
i don't know the answer that question
i i don't either but you know yesterday
when i'm uh
talking to noam chomsky here's a guy
that's been a professor at mit for
60-plus years right that's a long time
and i asked him i said do you love
america he says how do you love a
country
you can't love a country i love my kids
i love my family but you can't love a
country
what do you mean love a country i said i
can say i love america
he says i don't understand the concept
of loving a country right
i i ask you the question at the
beginning is one of the priorities to be
a cia agent to have the love of the
country you know they say
love of the game clause like you know
michael jordan in his contract that's
something with the bulls called the love
of the game clause like you can never
let me
stop me from playing a small little
pickup game in new york you can't stop
me because it's the love of the game
claus and all of his contracts
it concerns me if the ci agents that
they get in today
some of them actually don't like the
ideas america was founded on that scares
the hell out of me because that's where
you're not uh protecting the values that
you value that america was founded on
you're willing to fight for the values
that maybe your mom your dad a professor
at uc berkeley sold you on that you've
been convinced
that's the way to go and other countries
are a little bit more loyal to the
values that that country sold them on i
hope i'm wrong i hope our agents are
more
loyal to what america found was founded
on but uh
again who am i i'm just the guy well but
i think you're right i think you're on
to something i think if you if all you
do is hire for the individual
and the show that you are hiring you
know all the various elements of society
out there
um and those people you know that you
hire
you know aren't coming to the table
because of you know love of the team
love of the
the values love of the the ideas the
ideals then
yeah then eventually you're gonna have a
problem because you're gonna have a
group of individuals and look i don't
care you could have a conference room
full of uh uh you know diversity
and all you've got is you know maybe
you've got a conference room with
diverse idiots you could have a
homogenous conference room and you gotta
have a conference room full of
homogenous idiots right
doesn't matter you hire the smartest the
most confident the most capable skill
sets you've got
and it doesn't matter what they look
like right and so
that to me seems like it shouldn't be
that hard to understand
uh but no i i disagree with gnome i i
love america i love the ideals i love
the ideas
yeah and you know some people will say
well you know
you know your ideas are wrong or
whatever i don't i don't care right i
you know i'm i don't see anything i
don't see any contradiction in saying
you love america and
and you want it to be as best as it can
be uh look i
i don't i i don't care what anybody
thinks or believes or looks like or or
wants to be
right i don't need to celebrate your
ideas you don't need to celebrate
mine just get on with it be a good
honest
decent person be kind to people uh and
be a productive member of society
but you know get that [ __ ] out of my
wheelhouse right i don't
i i don't need you know to
all i care about is the character in the
content of your
your you know self as a human i thought
we were honestly there
and that's one of the few times i've
been disappointed uh in in the
recent past is when i realized that we
weren't there anymore and then we're
back to focusing on you know slicing and
dicing up the population and the into
you know people with
it doesn't make any sense to me and i
thought we were past it
we're on the same page i i again i saw
the commercial yesterday i'm like
wait what is this is this walmart trying
to say they're inclusive no no it's not
walmart that's cia yeah i thought it's a
walmart community
i thought it was walmart or an amazon
commercial that we hire everybody that's
my background all this stuff anyways
mike i've had a blast with you having
you on appreciate your time appreciate
your insight
no thank you man i've really enjoyed it
uh hopefully i wasn't too long with it
no i i uh if i didn't have an
appointment here right now i would have
stayed with you long i really enjoy
talking to you to hear your point of
view
on how things are and i salute you for
being a patriot and defending your
country and standing up for what your
country's values and principles are
thank you man i appreciate that very
much and hopefully we'll get a chance to
do this again somewhere down the road
i definitely hopefully next time i'm
going to be face to face take care buddy
thank you
thank you man bye-bye so after watching
this video do you like china anymore do
you trust him do you want to go there do
you want to go maybe there for vacation
do you want to be in business with them
i'm curious comment below if you enjoyed
this interview i got two other videos
i want you to watch one is with the
chief disguise officer jonah mendez
her job as a ci agent i think 28 years
was to go out there and help you have a
disguise where people cannot tell who
you are was you're kind of changing your
look
and the other one is nick mckinley who
was the modern day jack ryan if you've
seen the movie jack ryan
it's based on his life if you haven't
seen it click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you